South Korea says it made contact with
North Korea overnight on a newly
reopened communication channel the
hotline in Korea's Demilitarized Zone
was restored for the first time in
nearly two years
a spokesman for North Korean dictator
Kim jong-un announced the reopening on
state TV Ben Tracy is in Beijing with
the move that may put the u.s. and South
Korea at odds Ben good morning good
morning so it was just yesterday that
South Korea said that it wants these
formal high-level talks with North Korea
and they want them to take place next
week now the North has responded it
appears to be a step in that direction
and perhaps an easing at least
temporarily of some of the tensions on
the Korean Peninsula
now this communication channel that
we've been talking about between these
two countries it actually exists it's
set up in a border area called Pam moon
John that's inside the joint security
area of the Gimli demilitarized zone but
North Korea basically shut down that
hotline about two years ago in recent
weeks South Korean president moon jae-in
has offered to come to the table for
talks with the North without
preconditions and in advance of the
Winter Olympics which will take place
next month in South Korea now that
contradicts the latest stance of the
Trump administration which has said
talks could only occur if North Korea
ends its nuclear program mr. moon has
further annoyed the u.s. by saying he
can basically veto any military action
that might take place on the Korean
Peninsula now while all this is
happening us Intel
is actually detected signs that North
Korea may be ready to test another
intercontinental ballistic missile if
they do go through with that it could
happen in just a matter of days
Jeff Ben thank you very much